go this way go this way
these bees
oh yeah a bear been going through here
digging up penis
oh another one over there
i see bear markings on the trees back
here too
so if other bears coming through they
smell this they know he's the bear that
owns this place
so he chewed up the tree on this side
sees his marking post it goes all up the
hair
he's probably around here because you
see all those fresh marks where he dug
up those yellow jackets
he's right around here
this doesn't factor into my choice too
much where i'm gonna put to camp because
there's bears everywhere around here
but it's gonna be pretty sketchy
sleeping at night
but where i make my camp i'm gonna
determine by where is the best access
from the river to the lake and seeing
this big animal trail here tells me that
the moose use this spot because it's the
easiest place to walk back and forth
from the lake to the river so
what i'm thinking this is a prime spot
to make a camp
okay skye let's get this tarp up just
spread it out as far as you can see
we're gonna put it between these trees
here
and this is just gonna give us a nice
little dry spot we could sit under or
even
leave our firewood here let's try to get
this done before the rain hits
we might be using this tarp before we
even know it
[Music]
it's about two weeks out for moose
hunting season but it takes a lot of
work and it makes a lot of noise to put
up a moose hunting camp and i want to do
this early so i'm not making all that
noise and having to do all this work
during moose hunting
we could have set a wall tent here yeah
but this is something we could leave up
we don't have to take it down we don't
want to put a wall tent up and walk away
bear my tear the crap out of it
this is a big step for skylar because
he's hunted a lot of small game but now
he's got to think of the bigger animals
and
it's a lot more dangerous hunting big
games so he's going to stick close to me
and learn all these different moves we
do out here to try to get a good
opportunity to harvest something so it's
exciting for him
now we'll stand it up
okay tarps up beautiful view of the
river right here if any moose come out
you'll be able to see them on the bar
from here
a little bit of gas money some hard work
and this is how we put food on the table
out here in alaska
[Music]
you